RUNNING UP THE STAIRS.
>> I HAD PAJAMAS.
A LOT GOING ON AROUND HERE.
>> TEACH THE YOUNG BUCKS A
LESSON.
>> TOM AND I HAVE BEEN ON THE
COURSE MANY TIME, AT
TOURNAMENTS, OUT WITH FRIENDS.
TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT WITH A
COUPLE OF FANS, THAT WILL BE
NICE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW THESE YOUNG
GUYS SOMETHING ON THE COURSE.
LAST YEAR, TOMMY WAS ON THE
OTHER TEAM.
HAD TO GIVE HIM A BEAT DOWN.
THIS YEAR, IT WILL BE NICE TO
WIN IT WITH HIM.
>> I GOT FRIEND BARKLEY, WHEN HE
IS ON THE GOLF COURSE, HE MAKES
WAGERS.
>> YOU WILL HAVE A FRIENDLY
WAGER?
>> ALWAYS.
YOU HAVE TO STAY FOCUSED.
WHATEVER THOSE YOUNG GUYS WANT
TO BET.
I AM PROBABLY THE LOWEST PAID ON
THE GOLF COURSE, THOSE THREE ARE
HEAVY HITTERS.
WHATEVER THEY WANT, GOLF IS NOT
MY NUMBER ONE SPORT, AARON HAS A
WAY OF BRINGING OUT THE BEST IN
ME.
>> WHY DON'T YOU RETIRE AND GO
TO TV, I HEAR YOU GOT CHANGE
COMING YOUR WAY.
>> ALL IN DUE TIME.
YOU GUYS ARE DOING JUST FINE.
I LOVE YOUR SHOW.
SHAQ, WHEN I HAD DINNER WITH HIM
A FEW WEEKS AGO, THE BEST
CAMARADERIE.
EVERYBODY ON TELEVISION TRIES TO
EMULATE WHAT YOU DO.
A VERY DYSFUNCTIONAL FAMILY
DINNER.
YOU ARE DOING WELL.
>> WE HAD JOSH ALLEN ON THE
PODCAST, HE SAID THE EVENT WILL
BE OFF THE TEE.
DRIVING IT PAST YOU OLD GUYS.
DO YOU THINK THE SHORT GAME WILL
BE IMPORTANT?
DO YOU THINK YOU CAN KEEP UP
WITH THEM OFF THE TEE?
>> MY SCOUTING REPORT, I HEARD
THAT JOSH WAS TERRIBLE.
AND PAT PLAYED THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS, IN TAHOE, HASN'T
BROKEN 80 YET.
I THINK HE WAS CLOSER TO BE IN A
GROUP WITH YOU, NO OFFENSE,
CHARLES.
THAN ME IN TAHOE.
THE THING NOT TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT, TOM IS THE ULTIMATE
COMPETITOR, HE HAS BEEN TRAINING
HARD WITH HIS SWING COACH.
HE MAY HAVE AS MANY SWING
COACHES AS TONY ROMO.
HE WILL BE READY TO PLAY JUNE
1st.
>> I ALWAYS WONDER, WHEN YOU GO
FROM A SPORT, YOU ARE ACTUALLY
IN FRONT OF A CROWD IN A SPORT
THAT YOU TAKE FOR LEES YOUR.
ANY OF THE SAME NERVES, WHEN YOU
ARE ACTUALLY PLAYING FOOTBALL?
ANY OF THOSE NERVES COME UP?
>> OH, YES.
THE FIRST TIME, FIRST OF ALL, I
THINK THAT WHAT I LOVE, IT IS
FOR CHARITY.
WE RAISED $33 MILLION FOR
CHARITY.
BEING PART OF THIS SINCE THE
ORIGINAL MATCH, WITH TIGER, WAS
SPECIAL.
I REMEMBER GETTING OVER THE TEE
BOX IN THAT MATCH.
SCORING RANGE, THE FAIRWAYS ARE
THIS WEED.
I LOOKED DOWN THEA THE BALL, I
COULDN'T FEEL MY ARMS.
I SAID, HOW KIHIT IF I CAN'T
FEEL MY ARMS?
I FOUND MY WAY, TO GET IT
TOGETHER.
I NEVER FELT THAT ON THE
FOOTBALL FIELD.
ON THE GOLF COURSE, I FEEL THAT.
>> ARE YOU PLAYING MORE OR
PRACTICING MORE, LEADING INTO
THE MATCH?
>> I DON'T PRACTICE.
I GOT A GREAT PARTNER WHO HAS
BEEN TRAINING HARD FOR THIS.
OUT THERE SWINGING ON THE RANGE
WITH THE HELMET ON, TO GET BOTH
IN AT THE SAME TIME.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT OUR CHANCES.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GUYS ARE
AWARE, IT CAME ON LATE AT NIGHT
THE OTHER NIGHT.
WE DID VIOLATE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE
ANNUAL BLACK MASTERS.
SO NAMED BY CHARLES, FOR THE
FIRST TIME, HE WAS ABLE TO CLAIM
THE BLACK JACKET.
ANYTHING YOU LIKE TO SAY TO
CHARLES, WHO IS BASKING IN THE
GLORY OF HIS CHAMPIONSHIP?
>> GO AHEAD.
>> OUR TEAM WAS ON THE RANGE,
CHARLES.
I HAVE BEEN IMPRESSED.
I HAVE BEEN AT TAHOE 17 YEARS,
EVERYTHING TWO-HANDED,
RIGHT-HANDED, LEFT-HANDED, TO
THE HITS AND NO HITS, I AM HAPPY
FOR YOU BIG FELLOW.
I AM PROUD OF YOU.
I DON'T SEE SHAQ OUT THERE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH THAT.
>> I HAD ONE MATCH WITH A
45-FOOT PUTT TO BEAT CHARLES, I
BEAT HIM AND I RETIRED AFTER
THAT.
>> YOU HAD BUBA WATSON WITH YOU,
TOO.
>> DOESN'T MATTER.
>> I DON'T REMEMBER ANYTHING
THAT THEY SAID JUST NOW.
>> NOW, KEPY IS MESMERIZED.
>> TOM BRADY, AARO